hi Santina okay all right our first
victim of the Fatal Feast how are you
doing how are you feeling being in jury
all the things I am feeling
better I was a little bit emotional when
I left however I'm feeling great I'm
injury
um I'm around the nature I get a lot of
tea I get a lot of naps so I'm happy
yeah those naps come short in that house
for sure eh
um so we got to talk about last night
because obviously you know it was a
unanimous vote uh to to vote you out
what do you think that's saying about
the dynamic in the house right now
I think that it just shows really where
the alliances are in the house
who and who's basically just telling you
what you want to hear for their game and
I respect it I get it it's the brother I
understand so
right right okay well I gotta know
um with the Fatal feast
we saw that there was a chain of safety
and when you heard that there was a
chain of safety what were you thinking
like who first of all who were you
hoping was going to pick you
so I was hoping that hope was going to
pick me okay
okay you let me down a little bit but I
knew once I heard there was a chain of
safety that I wasn't safe and I just
knew that I had a really big chance that
I'd be going home
okay so had hope picked you for the
chain of safety how would you have
played that
so if hope picked me I would have picked
either Daniel C or Anika
um okay okay and why would you have
picked them
um because previous to that night I told
KUSI that I was gonna give her my
loyalty and I knew that Daniel C and
Anika were aligned with her so I just
wanted to show her where my loyalty was
by picking one of them okay all right I
make sense okay so when you were talking
to Shania and Claudia there was a moment
and I just want to read the quotes I
don't want to get it wrong you said hope
you don't see them in jury the next in
the next couple of weeks so in your mind
what do you think they need to change in
order to you know change their situation
in the house
she just has to kind of Step Up her game
a little bit and maybe just give her
loyalty to someone on the other side as
Anika or KUSI because I think that
they're going to be going after them and
with Claudia like she's just she's she's
a big Target like not yeah like she just
plays the game very well and I think
eventually she will become a Target
um okay it's good to get some insight
because you're you're fresh out you're
fresh out so
um I gotta know
if you were picked to stay or in your
plea to stay pardon me you said
that you were basically like you know
you've enjoyed your time here were you
hoping that at any point you would stay
or did you kind of know that you were
going home
so I knew I was gonna go home
um and even if I wasn't gonna go home I
didn't want to say anything
wrong to make it seem like I'm just
saying these things to make me stay I
didn't want to throw anybody under the
bus even though it's big brother
um so I just you know I just wanted to
show my appreciation of me being there
right right well I mean it makes sense
you know it's a big it's a big um big
moment
um now you had been
secret HOH you've been HOH twice
and all right and I mean you've seen
some ups and downs
um you've had a lot of moments in this
game so what was a highlight of your bb
can game
like in general of just being in the
house
I mean if you were to look back and say
someone was like all right what's the
biggest thing you did in that house or
what's the best thing you know what's
the Highlight what's the most memorable
thing in your bb gun can game for you
I would say possibly being the invisible
HOH because I wanted to get out Dennis
like I wanted him to get out from week
one
um so I would say probably being the
invisible HOH and just plain that week
as I did and keeping it to myself
um but also Canada Saving me was a huge
moment in my game so okay okay amazing
um shout out to Canada okay
throughout the season uh we've seen you
work with different types of people but
more recently you had to fight for you
know you had to kind of fight alone in
that house so I guess I'm wondering why
do you think that was
I think because
even for myself like in the outside life
I'm kind of just like a lone wolf and I
do things on my own and I think maybe
that was my downfall in there
um but I also had a hard time trusting
people and giving them my trust because
it was broken so early in the game by
Kai and Zach that I just wasn't sure who
I could give my trust to and giving it
to Hope really proved to me that I
shouldn't be giving it to anybody
okay all right now I always like to ask
people what is your biggest like
personal takeaway from Big Brother
because speaking of someone who's been
in that house I definitely you know I
had I I took a lot of of life lessons
from this house so what would you say is
your life lesson from Big Brother Canada
I would say that just being okay with
who I am
and that it's okay to be quiet and shy
or just be on your own or whatever it's
just okay to be who you are and I think
that's one thing I really took away
nice all right well you know you might
be out of the house but you're not out
of the game Santina
so in your mind what makes a player
worthy of your vote
oh a player who has played the game the
opposite of a floater uh someone who is
not afraid to make big moves and go
against uh the house and the other house
guests and just someone in general would
play in the game I don't want to see
someone up there that has just floated
their way through and hasn't done it
really anything in the game at all okay
so would you say you like what kind of
game do you respect more you're a social
or strategic
I would say oh ah
both but more strategic
um and competitive someone who's won a
lot
um but I mean social is good too because
like obviously they've made it to the
end just with a social game which is
strategically good too right right all
right well I gotta know as of right now
who do you think is winning bbcan 11.
think that KUSI
inspect her so much even myself being
put up on the block by her I respect her
move and I hope she wins all right all
right well thank you again Santina you
are now officially a part of this crazy
BB King family so you stuck with us now
uh and you know you made it to Journey
you have so much more to experience and
still enjoy so we can't wait to see how
it all turns out congratulations thank
you Brittany all right thanks Aunt Tina
bye bye